apparently i already asked you the
trivia question earlier about romeo
cornell and you got it wrong so i get
the first pick is that fair oh god you
take the first pick go ahead i'll give
it to you let me just go to tony corenti
then let me go right there first off if
there was a
person that
um looked like they could be maybe your
twin brother or like your de facto other
like something yeah it's you i i watch
tony karenti sometimes and think is that
oreo in the uniform there
but either way he gets the call because
that was a horrible call last night that
really was that game was in the balance
and it was a chance to where new
england's defense had played great you
know had missed some opportunities and
here they go it's 6-3
they get a interception and they're
going to have a short field and you're
going whoa
this is going to be a game this is going
down to the wire i mean there's no doubt
about it and kansas city's in trouble
and that call right there i don't get it
we didn't hear a whistle until the
patriots player was at least 10 yards
down the sideline um i i don't buy it i
think that was a one of the first of
probably many we'll see of the mahomes
the mahomes taking care of the golden
child uh award right there
all right my first pick a guy who showed
up in yesterday's draft a sunday
surprise in a bad way goat in a very bad
way nick mullins the now former starting
quarterback at the san francisco 49ers
in place of jimmy garoppolo kyle
shanahan the coach of the team said
yesterday that he hasn't decided who the
quarterback will be i think he has i
think you know chris i think we all know
it can't be nick mullins again not after
that performance on sunday night it was
horrific it was horrible
they they they they would have won the
game if they had gone with cj beathard
from the get-go they would won the game
if they'd put jimmy garoppolo out there
with his bad ankle they'd have won the
game yeah uh you know i i can't disagree
with that i mean that game was there to
be had they could have controlled it
from the start and he played horrible
and listen mike it's hard for me not to
go with the damn quarterback i saw last
night i mean if we're going to talk
about goats in a bad way aaron rodgers
yeah right
brian hoyer i mean he it's like he
watched nick mullen on sunday night and
was like you did stupid i'll one-up your
stupid and times it by two i mean it
really was i i just i still can't get
over it i'm sure belichick is he
probably had a hard time sleeping on the
plane ride home he can't believe he had
a quarterback that was so unaware of the
football game and unaware of what his
own talents were
that's to me just mind-boggling so yes
he deserves that the goat in a bad way
award there
yeah that was my number two on the list
as well i'm gonna go now
uh
to arizona
and i'm gonna i'm gonna make cliff
kingsbury
uh
one of the goats this week because i
don't know what the hell they're doing
with kyler murray right and i i think
that what's happening is
teams are figuring out what kingsbury
wants to do and they're taking it away
and he's not zigging when they zag and
he needs to self scout himself as you
would say yeah they need to figure out
what you know what defenses are doing
and react to it better because they
should have beaten the lions they should
have beaten the panthers they should be
at least three and one if not four and
oh so off we go uh there it is what do
we got here what's the stat uh
that's the thing moved on me so i don't
know what the stat is go ahead make your
pick there's a stat about kyler murray
yeah but no you know i mean just on that
game in general i i'm i'm that's one of
the first games i want to watch today
when i look at film just to look at like
what carolina did to that arizona
offense certainly and you know last week
here it is here it is
fewest passing yards with 24 or more
completions since 1950 kyler murray
number one with 133 yards yeah it's
passing yards with 24 or more and he's
number four
uh last year with 100 he's got two spots
on the top four with shane matthews and
jp lostman so you know they got and we
talk about drew brees not getting the
ball down the field he's not on this
list all right what are you going to do
no you're right well they use the pass
game as like an extension of their run
game you know that's what they do it's
oh screen instead of running the ball up
the middle oh another wide receiver
screen instead of running the ball up
the middle so you're right it's a lot of
that and they're gonna have to find some
ways to kind of push the ball down the
field and be a little different that way
there's no question mike i think that's
a very fair point that you bring up
there i mean i don't even know where to
go who do i frame who do i frame for
dallas's issues i i mean mike nolan of
course the defensive coordinator is what
i want to talk about but i also just
like it's everybody it's the jones
family it's mike mccarthy i don't i
guess so what i'm saying is is
everybody except the offensive coaches
in dallas i don't know what the hell
we're doing on defense i don't know and
i this is bigger than just like hey you
look like crap on the field what is
someone confused about and what you
might have heard with me say on the the
podcast there with our little clip you
know they're playing a defensive scheme
that doesn't fit the players they have
on the field
and that to me is where like where did
this get lost in translation in the off
season to go
wait
our guys don't fit what he wants to do
we need to get new guys or wait we don't
hire this guy
and we keep our guys and we do something
similar to what we did to me that's the
biggest issue with the cowboys right now
this is the worst year to do that too
with no off season with no preseason
games you can't even you can't even try
i know jam the square pegs into the
round holes before it's time to play the
games to count tony dungy made that
point on sunday night in the digital
stuff that we do after half time at the
sunday night football game that you get
rid of rod marinelli
and you replace him with somebody's
gonna run a completely different scheme
he needs his players yeah for that
scheme to work yes all right uh the last
one for me and i don't know who this is
i don't know if it was a trainer if it
was a doctor whoever cleared makai
bechten to play on thursday night oh
what the hell was that for the jets well
he can't play he can't start because
he's injured we're going to put him in
uniform in case we need him well what
the hell if he can't play he can't play
if he can play he can play if he can't
play he can't play there's no in between
we're going to use him if we if we have
to use him he's either good not good to
go or he's not good to go and then you
see the picture of him on the sideline
where he's clearly in pain and he looks
like he wants to go find out who said it
was okay for him to play and and say
something to them so i i just that that
that that still confuses me five days
later yeah that's my last one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports